[Musique]
je pense qu'un potager sa cultive une
sorte de patience en ce printemps 2020
très particulier le potager de servir
d'exutoire pour certains et offrir une
belle source de produits maraîchers
frais et des fines herbes odorantes même
sur un simple balcon on peut arriver à
récolter de juteuses tomates et de
savoureux concombres les plantes ont des
besoins juste comme les humains et on
commence on tond potager c'est de
connaître leurs besoins pour prendre
soin pour tous la saison la première
chose c'est vraiment de voir combien de
soleil on reçoit dans notre potager
l'orientation sud où as tu reçois le
plus de lumière site à 8 heures de
soleil direct tu peux pousser tous qui
produit à des différents légumes des
différents fruits
si on a environ quatre à six heures
on peut pousser tous qui est légumes
racines on pense aux carottes aux bêtes
reuve panais et cetera
si j'ai pas de soleil ou à peu près pas
de soleil est ce que j'oublie mon
potager c'est un peu beaucoup de lumière
tu peux vraiment faire un production de
verdure le basilic par contre est bon
coup du salaire je dirais un 8 heures
serait l'idéal
jeanine tout comme fait ni travail pour
sentir urbain organismes de verdissement
social depuis 1993 sentier urbain
s'emploiera pro chez l'humain que de la
nature en transformant des terrains
vacants îlots de chaleur en espaces
verts pour les citoyens comment est ce
que je peux amener plus de biodiversité
dans mon potager un conseil ça serait de
distribuer les écoles dans le potager
par exemple peut mettre tout livre blanc
de la même famille au même endroit les
disperser intercalé avec des plantes
plus aromatiques ou des fleurs qui vont
attirer les insectes pollinisateurs
mais distraire les ravageurs réfléchir
aussi est-ce que ont beau de mes plans
plus grands comme les tomates ou mes
plantes qui vont grimper comme mère qu
est ce que je peut planter peut-être
et légumes racines qui vont avoir le
temps de pousser ou fait des petites
verdure que je vais récolter plus
rapidement si on est en balcon on peut
vraiment favorisés de faire débat qu'on
boit ou des smart people to 1
jardinières alors même si c'est dans ton
couronne arrière peut trés ça serait
mieux de faire don des différents bacs
en bois où c'est plonge surélevée si on
a un terreau contaminées en dessous tu
veux vraiment mettre un genre de
géotextile pour faire 1 division entre
ça mais si vous savez l'historique de
ton frère tu peux aussi juste cultivés
en plein de faire une fois l'emplacement
et les contenants choisi le choix de
terrou est très important si tu va
utiliser quelque chose qui est très
petit
je pense à un smart potes ou jardinières
là ça serait important d'utiliser un
promix c11 différents mélanges que tu
peux retrouver dans une pépinière qui
est de la mousse de tourbe et les roches
volcaniques qui est vraiment un très
très léger et qui a besoin de beaucoup
d'eau et puis dans les gros bacs
je dirais que tu peux mettre la terre
noire avec aussi un 10 pouces de
compostage sur le dessus
ici on avait notre pacte et j'ai divisé
en pieds carrés pour nous aider à aller
diviser et à prévoir notamment nagement
ont dû commencer potager on pense à un
pied carré et tous les différents
légumes qu'on peut mettre dans un pied
carré
si on pense à intermat ça prend un pied
carré on a placé nos cultures qui vont
monter plus grands comme un automate
notre poivrons notre basilique ici pour
qu'ils reçoivent plus de soleil avec
notre sud ici et on a mis des fines
herbes entre non les tuer au bout qui on
peut les mettre plus serré donc quatre
là dessus pour un pied carré pour la
plupart des végétaux on s'assure qu'une
niveau tard soit égal avec le niveau de
meute
les tomates ont le super fort de pouvoir
faire des racines à partir de leur tige
donc faut pas avoir peur de les enterrer
un peu plus profond on peut même faire
une butte au tour
[Musique]
dans un genre d' ignares de même on
pourrait mettre jusqu'à trois sortes de
finale j'en mettrais pas plus parce que
c'est quand même serré pour notre semi
directe coriandre ici je vais faire dieu
peut-il inc c'est que ça le principe
d'un semis direct
puis l'heure je vais mettre un semences
et chaque pouce environ c'est vraiment
correct si plus tôt c'est juste avoir ça
en général
après pour le couvrir on a besoin
environ deux fois le montrons des terres
que la diamètre du som ans après je vais
prendre la main registre ap légèrement
là dessus ceux qui couchent concombre il
préfère beaucoup le fmi direct versus
une transplantation ils sont assez
sensibles des racines donc par exemple
si j'ai un smartphone comme ça je
pourrais même place et ça en triangle
il me faire 3 cm direct de courge ou de
concombre et ça va être des plantes qui
vont grimper
donc on peut tout de suite installé une
pyramide de bambou pour les aider à gré
pfff n'importe quel engrais naturel
qu'on utilise on peut regarder la
concentration en azote phosphore
potassium la seule ça vaille tous qui
fouillent âge donc masse de feuilles
phosphore c'est plus enracinement et
potassium ses fruits et fleurs non plus
la saison avance plus on va aller
chercher un engrais qui ont une plus
grande concentration de potassium versus
azote parce que c'est plus la saison
avance tombeurs des fleurs et des fruits
alors mes cultures plus gourmands donc
ils vont faire un fruit comme les
tomates aubergines poivrons
je vais y aller avec une bonne poignée
autour puis les cultures plus de
feuillages je peux y aller avec une plus
petite poignée juste une demi poignet
que je mets autour voilà ne reste plus
qu'à arroser et être à l'écouté des
besoins de notre potager des fois dans
la vie on est très impatient pour pour
que on a les choses maintenant il fait
un potager ça nous apprend à ralentir de
prendre 1 journée à la fois des côtes et
les besoins d'être en harmonie avec la
nature
[Musique]